called road runner a film about anthony
bourdain and it's in theaters today
as you know he tragically died from
suicide in 2018
but he's the narrator through much of
this documentary
and this documentary is from an
oscar-winning director morgan uh neville
who uh also did i believe uh
10 feet from stardom i believe that's
the name of the documentary about backup
singers or 20 feet from stardom great
documentary i'm
huge into documentary so i cannot wait
to see this and i think i'm gonna go to
the theaters to see this because
i've been going back to movie theaters
and it is glorious
so um what's interesting about this is
that
they started using ai in order to create
deep fakes of bourdain's
voice for key moments in the film
where they didn't have him saying
something and there's all these great
documentary techniques if you've ever
seen the kid stays in the picture
they might do animations or take
pictures
and blur them or ken burns will pan
across an old photo
there's all these great techniques to
take boring documentaries
that are told typically through stock
footage or just static images or people
basically recounting stories and now we
have a new one
in the toolkit and it's a little bit
concerning to some people but i think
i'm falling on
uh being delighted by this so there is a
section
and this comes from a new yorker profile
written by
helen rosner and she asked neville where
the he got the audio from
and according to the article there's a
moment in the film where a friend of
bourdain's is reading an email sent to
him from bourdain
and bourdain was known as being a great
friend to a lot of people and
um that makes his suicide even more
tragic if you are
thinking of taking this terrible step
please
call your friends they want you in the
world i mean i think
losing anthony bourdain is just so
brutal
um he was just such an amazing human
being on so many levels
but in the email bourdain writes you
are successful and i am successful and
i'm wondering are you happy
wow i mean that is a deep comment
um and i think it speaks to what a lot
of people who are successful
go through which is sometimes you're on
the journey and climbing the mountain
and
and trying to get to a certain
destination uh whether that's wealth
fame
uh love happiness you kind of get there
and you wonder am i actually happy
well here's the quote from the article
there were three quotes there
i wanted his voice for that there were
no recordings of neville explained so he
got in touch with the software company
gave it about a dozen hours of
recordings and he said
i created an ai model for his voice oh
my god this is amazing
and if you've been on tiktok recently
and you've seen the person who does
imitations of tom cruise we're
crossing the uncanny valley if you don't
know what the uncanny valley is
that's the point at which these ais and
deep fakes
in this referencing uh deep fake
specifically it's when
your mind believes you're actually
hearing that person in other words you
can't tell
the young county valley is more about ai
and
sentient lives you can look it up online
but in this case it means did you buy it
did you actually think it was anthony
bourdain uh and so
let's listen to the clip and i'll make
some comments about it
you were successful and i am successful
and i'm wondering
are you happy okay now i'm just going to
play it again
and i'm going to play it at a lower
volume here while i talk over wondering
are you happy it does sound a little
robotic on the margins you can
you can hear that tinniness but boy
if are you happy i saw this in a
actual trailer and i did watch the
trailer actually and i didn't
pick this up but and that is means
across the uncanny valley other moments
of uncanny valley that may have not
crossed for you
um scorsese did the irishmen and they
and they made everybody look younger
that was clearly did not cross the
valley for me but luke skywalker
in the mandalorian spoiler alert luke
skywalker shows up in return of the jedi
kind of
format post return of the jedi um
i bought it um maybe i wanted to buy it
and so that's part of this
but here we go we're now at a point
where
a dead person could be in a film or a
younger version of a person
and just closing the loop on this great
article that found this nugget so
congratulations to the uh
to the reporter uh who actually figured
out that this you know
he asked a really good question like
where did you get these clips
if you watch the film other than that
line you mentioned you probably
don't know what the other lines are that
were spoken by the ai and you're not
going to know
neville says we can have a documentary
ethics panel about it later and that's
one of the things about documentary
films
because they are you know an
interpretation
by a filmmaker of a subject they
have very loose rules that's why you'll
see you know in a narrative film
based on a true story kind of gives them
a little bit of um
ability to wiggle around is this
actually this actually happened did
these conversations happy
happen anyway i i think this is amazing
i think bourdain would love the fact
that you know they
they did this and you could actually
hear his voice say things and it had
more resonance of course you could use
this in a cheesy way
and you could do it in a disrespectful
way but this is the world
right and i think about all the
wonderful possibilities here it would
have been amazing to see
heath ledger's joker again now is it
disrespectful or is it
uh an homage or is it honorable to bring
him back i think it's honorable to bring
him back and
i would love to uh see
philip seymour hoffman you know do a
comedic role again i mean talk about a
tragedy again another overdose just
this artist overdosing is just so tragic
um
but you know you remember along came
polly the amazing ben stiller film
uh and he a lot of people say that i
play basketball like him and
the rain dance scenes amazing maybe we
can drop
one into the youtube video here uh
without getting in copyright
trouble put in a little box and tilt it
and zoom in on it and
we'll probably get past the youtube
censors uh but wouldn't it be amazing to
see him do a spin out of that film i
think they were always thinking about
having that child actor do another
film um and just putting it out there
if somebody out there is an ai
specialist and they think that this is
as intriguing as i think it is i would
love to back a music startup
i'm just thinking about music right now
i would love to back a music startup
where i could say i want to hear mark
knopler of dire schrade's
um wish you were here by pink floyd i
would like to hear pink floyd
uh and roger waters cover this dillon
track
tangled up in blue this could be an
amazing
unlock for creativity to be able uh
an art to be able to do mashups now some
people might consider this sacrilegious
or
you know against some human
purity test but the way i look at it is
we created the ai
we should get to benefit from it and
what an amazing startup that would be
if we could take uh people's voices and
uh artwork and ip and reinterpret them
even if it was a tool i mean if you came
out with a tool that allowed somebody to
put in a bunch of videos or a bunch of
audio and then
let the user you know take ownership of
exporting that ip
that would take you out of the ip
business
or you could be in the ip business and
create this technology
and then go to an estate and say hey
elvis presley estate
we would like to make these 10 tracks of
the elvis ai
singing these 10 songs would that be
interesting to you
we live in the future and i love it so
give me some startup ideas people i
i got checks i got money sitting here i
want to invest in some crazy
let's go
over the past few years everybody's been
talking about no code and
one of the first no code apps was bubble
you've heard of bubble
bubble empowers people to design and
launch their own apps
marketplaces or tools without ever
needing coding skills or pricey
engineers bubble offers a digital editor
and cloud hosting platform for as little
as 29
a month users can build pretty much any
complex web app from marketplaces to
social networks to sas
and more so why is bubbles so great for
founders because
you can spend 10 times less on building
out your mvp
your minimum viable product i have so
many people come to me and say hey jcal
give me money i want to build this
and i'm like have you built an mvp and
they're like no i don't have a developer
i'm like well
use bubble use no code drag and drop
elements in their visual editor
and you can quickly and easily build a
powerful app you can
go from idea to a launchable product in
a matter of days
or weeks not months or quarters or even
years and they handle
all the annoying stuff like the
deployment and hosting
of your app so you can focus on your
product and your customers
bubble has over 1 million users
worldwide
and they enable over 1 billion in
business volume bubble is offering one
month free
on any of their paid plans ranging from
their personal plan of 29
a month all the way to their production
plan of 529
a month but act fast because they're
only offering this deal
to the first 500 redemptions again head
to bubble dot io slash twist
bubble dot io slash twist and snag one
of those 500 coupons
for your first month free